this podcast and every other podcast on
my channel is brought to you by the
people on patreon austin busy troy i
assume all so busy it's uh the second
ever mike and alana special
people are excited people are talking
about this everyone's ever hotly
anticipated it's all over the internet
um front page of reddit
i have allergies
it's like 10 p.m for you
making it work boiling as well here
still sweating up storm it went down and
come back up again it's really hot here
too what is it there
it's i i mean i think like 32 in the
middle of the day but exactly 30 but not
terrible
it's like we don't have air con as a
country no i know like i think i said
this before when i lived in san
francisco it's
the weekend that pax west is
because i always know because half of
ign wasn't there and half was and the
ones who were there were like i don't
know what to do with my pets because
nobody has like fans or air conditioning
in san francisco
i when i lived actually in the city only
had a heater
that didn't work
and because my studio apartment was so
small it was also dangerously close to
my
bed like almost fire hazard close to the
bed it was touching the side of it and
that was the only place i could put the
bed so i was like
probably never going to use the heater
um no air conditioning whatsoever
whereas here i have it running
constantly and so then when i go outside
it's like a
because it's there it's la it's like
visiting la it's just islands it feels
like you're constantly like you're
working out where your next aircon
window is moving between that space in
the summer there it's fair enough i hate
that in cities where it's the opposite
which i imagine probably happens in the
uk
more than
l.a obviously it happens in new york all
the time
it happens in melbourne where if it's
winter and everything's hot inside
i actually can't stand that i'd prefer
you leave it like slightly cool because
then you walk into a hot environment
have to take all your clothes off and
then you get sweaty and then you go back
outside
up and down up and down throughout the
day yeah 100 the same i i don't do well
with temperature changes in general but
yeah in the winter when yeah it's awful
just the water what is the weather like
where you are great this is what this is
what people tune in for but i am
genuinely this is the content this is
the content
i'm in manchester so it's it's a bit
cooler up here which is nice but still
but you still have the um stereotypical
gray uk weather
um
less and less with every passing year um
yeah um so but no we're in we're in
summer and it's nice right now but it's
just yet we're going through the the
heatwave i got to do um i went down to
london um for a like a game game game
dev meetup thingy um and just was packed
hot trains both ways it was fun
um but yeah that's fun hey you made it
through
and we're going to hang out with phil
spencer so he did what a nice guy what a
nice he's nice he's a really nice guy
isn't he really
we we he came over to me he's like he's
like i don't think we've ever actually
talked to each other in person right i'm
like no i don't think we have this is
this is weird um so yeah it's nice nice
tagging only good things to say about
phil like
i think
that's the general opinion right yeah i
think it's
yeah no he's really good he he i like
basically yeah i like i like i like the
people at his level who actually kind of
travel to local development communities
and go hey so tell me about the uk tell
me what's going on here and what you
need that's just that goes a long way
that goes such a change from
matric to like just such different
approaches
to everything that they're that they're
doing yeah i didn't know that he did
that kind of stuff like obviously he
always makes it out to
i don't know whatever i see man see him
at the game awards every year i imagine
um he does go to e3 like it's stuff that
you wouldn't have to go to and always
spends time talking to everybody i think
it was at the game awards
i could be completely wrong about this
but i believe he just spent a bunch of
time
talking to somebody's dad because they
happened to be there
uh so
phil just it wasn't at the game awards
um it was a uk event but it was he just
like someone's dad was there didn't know
anything about video games and so they
introduced him to phil they're like this
is phil spencer and their dad would have
had no idea who it was and they had this
like hour-long conversation where phil
was just talking to this dad because he
was like you don't know anyone like he's
just i bet that's refreshing i bet if
you're phil spencer it's really nice to
run into someone at a game event who has
no idea who you are i imagine that's
actually quite relaxing and satisfying
just have a nice conversation with a
stranger because you walk into that room
and everyone in the room clocks you and
knows you're oh it's spencer you know
that's that's a big deal um yeah that's
good
you know what he said to me
he said we've not met but i i've i've
i've heard your podcast quite a bit so
if you are listening phil hello
oh no we take it all back he's in the
audience
whenever anyone in the industry tells me
they watch anything that i make like um
tim when i spoke to him the other day
was like i've seen all your videos about
your migraines how are you doing and i
was like why are you watching those like
do something else come on because then
i'm like i didn't make them for you and
now i feel weird about it
i do feel like i've i've i definitely
like on twitter like have like followed
or like said hello to like a bunch of
like youtubers i basically feel like i
have a lot
of um asymmetric like bi-directional
asymmetrical relationships with
youtubers there where like i'll talk to
someone who i'm like a fan of their
youtube videos and then they'll be a fan
of my games and we'll kind of talk past
each other a little bit
it's true i highly recommend it uh so
today
if we did not sit to talk about phil
spencer or the weber who we're following
asynchronous youtubers
which is an important topic but not
today
um we're going to talk about prey i
really wanted to talk about it uh the
i guess i should intro the show five
minutes in hi everyone welcome to play
watch listen i'm alana that's mike
bethel i'm a video game writer he's
video game writer and also director
um and we want to talk about prey which
apparently is hulu's most successful
launch of all time is it on hulu in
disney plus over here i thought so it's
so weird because i guess disney owns
hulu i don't know why they yeah we get
we get yeah basically if it's on like
espn or hulu in america it's all on
disney plus that seems great
that's cool that seems much better would
prefer it um yeah it's hulu over here
and it was their most successful
original tv show or film
launch of all time
which doesn't really surprise me
considering how much people are talking
about it um but also that it if you
didn't already know prey is a predator
movie so it is a massive well-known ip
interesting that they didn't put it in
the title though um mike what did you
think what'd you think of pray
i really liked it yeah i really liked it
i just realized by the way i'm on a
crappy connection so let's let's do this
live on the show i'm going to switch to
the better connection see if my video
quality improves for you because i
imagine i'm quite blocky let me try
you're actually fine oh in which case i
will not touch anything yeah but if it
gets bad let me know um
i really liked it i thought it was
really cool i i loved i loved original
predator
it was one of those movies i remember
i think when i turned like 15 or
something i remember my dad basically
sitting me down and being like son
there's some movies i want to watch with
you and it was like predator
terminator thing like yeah it was all of
those films i feel like a lot of people
had that moment with their probably you
know usually with a dad um and uh yeah
i'm predator was one of those and i just
i just you know blew my mind as a as a
teenager
franchise it's going up and down right
i think it's kind of like
i did i yo
i think the only one i remember like
genuinely like really thinking was
pretty good was predators i think that
one is that's the one with adrian brodie
as the least believable action star ever
it's adrian brody also sorry to video
watches i just moved the wrong window
okay but yeah that one i remember that
one and i think laurence fishburne as
well if i remember right but like that's
that's that one i remember really
enjoying um i think the others i think
it's always been a tricky one because i
feel like a lot of predator movies don't
seem to get what made predator good or
them or the studio kind of wanted to
push away from that and i feel like prey
feels like a return to form of like oh
you got predator
and you understood what predator was
about and you made another predator
movie i respect that you know yeah i
mean they are the two i guess i have
seen all the predator movies um and i
just didn't realize so
i just because there aren't that many
there's predator predator two predators
i haven't seen predators
the predator and prey
yes
and then you've got the alien verses
versus predator obviously video game
lots of video games of that the the
comics which i read as a kid of alien
versus predator um so there's it's been
around did the game come before
the movie alien versus predator
yeah well comics come first then there
was the game the first one at least and
then the movies happen
that's really cool but i don't think any
of them are based i don't think any of
them are based on the canon of any
previous version i think the comics tell
a different story to the games which
have a different story to the movies i
think that's right the game in the comic
might be closer related but yeah i
didn't even really realize that the
games had story i thought they were
really really honest alien versus
yeah wow there are a lot of alien
games dating back to 1982
wow
look at you go quite the franchise but
you're right i think that um
the point of the original predator
is that they needed to start acting like
prey to be able to succeed they were
acting like predators and that failed
them so then they start acting like prey
i think that might even be like a line
in that movie
the secret the thing i've heard said the
summary i've heard is that it's a
slasher movie that costs like the muscle
men of the 80s as the high school
students and in that contest it contacts
the whole movie makes sense like it's
very simple
the whole that's how you make the
predator seem badass is you make him
absolutely annihilate all those blokes
right like that's that's you know that's
how they did it but you're absolutely
right like yeah it's that movie is about
learning to use wits rather than guns
um and and yeah acting like acting like
prey and being defensive because you
can't be the predator of the predator
it's clearly op i never actually thought
about predators being like a slasher
movie villain which is totally true
because it is i mean it's
unbelievably
like it is
virtually unbeatable it has a gadget for
everything
um
[Music]
and i guess
like the the point of the predator if i
remember correctly i'm pretty sure this
is correct i'm sure there are plenty of
fans of this franchise who are
infuriated listen to this um is they go
to different planets and
it's it's a hunt like they are trying to
prove that they can kill anything on
that planet so they are obsessed with
just being a predator um and having no
prey i guess it's yeah it's about
finding the the dominant species yeah
hunting that and then
the slight tweaks and all and the first
three movies all kind of focus on that
in some form or another predators has a
really good premise which i won't spoil
for you if you go and watch it which but
it's the same idea yeah i don't think
and then i think it's i think it's the
predator that introduces the idea that
as well as doing it for sport
they're they're like copying people
copying the dna of all these alpha
species
improve themselves yes
which i guess also makes sense i like
that as a premise too but yeah i thought
it was interesting that this movie like
it showcased that in some cool ways like
you see that at first he's killed
spoilers spoilers oh yeah spoilers
absolutely
the snake
um which
would give you the assumption that the
predator thinks that the snake might be
the apex species and then the bear
um which damn if you could kill a bear
you got to get off in between right is
it wolf it's snake wolf bear yeah and
all the bison were the french um
yeah it's a lovely idea that that works
very because you completely assume it's
yeah yeah one hundred percent
yeah i didn't even know they were there
and i know this isn't the first time
that predator has been to earth because
there are references to predator being
uh uh in like ancient egypt
or whatever so it's not the first time
but it was that's non-canon i'm gonna be
so nerdy on this podcast tonight if i
get something wrong there's the comments
are gonna definitely correct me in the
comments do it 10 times and if you get
friends to come view the video and do it
as well that'd be great i don't think it
was in a movie at least but i um the
pres
i think you're thinking of alien versus
predator where they have kind of these
pyramids they keep the aliens correct
have been coming here for thousands of
years but yeah aliens versus predator is
not is oh no sorry apologies oh here we
go alien vs predator is canon to the
predator franchise but not nightly
franchise
because in predators in the predator why
do i know this on a wall surprise
wouldn't have expected it there is a
prop hanging up on the wall in um the
predator which which is a weapon i think
used in alien versus prior to the movie
so that is canon to this world so alien
there you go so yes you're absolutely
right they they came over into egypt um
there you go and this is their first
time
coming back in a while i think this is a
reboot this is a reboot like this feels
like a reboot i think so yeah um
so i
liked the movie
but i didn't love it as much as
everybody else it's just part of what i
wanted to talk about because i and i
don't know if that's the same thing that
you had with everywhere everything
everything everywhere all at once where
i was just seeing people rave about it
the way that i felt about it was like
this is pretty good for a predator movie
but ultimately just an okay
film and i think
part of that was a thing that i feel
like i'm seeing more recently or maybe
i'm just becoming more aware of it i
think i'm seeing it more often
is
there was no tension for me
because almost nobody was a real
character
um i think the protagonist like
definitely has an arc that's that that i
enjoyed the arc of like everybody
doubting that you can do things you
failing repeatedly proving almost to
yourself that you can't do things but
then your failure almost being your
success and recognizing it and leaning
into it i thought that was cool
um but she didn't have much personality
or character or i couldn't tell you her
interests outside of that like i don't
really know who she was but it's it's
more that she was always going to
succeed and it's not like that doesn't
exist um
you know in for a lot of heroes
protagonist across the board but in this
case i was just like everyone else is
going to die and you are going to live
and your your point is going to be
proven and i felt like that just took a
lot of tension away from me again
because i knew that
she was going to be fine and her point
was going to be proven no matter what
um
and yeah the the
all of the other i don't know her
friends i guess family whatever they
would be um
also just lacked personality so so
because of that i never was attached to
anybody i didn't care when anybody died
and i'm not really sure how that
happened i liked the main guy her
brother maybe frank he was really good i
saw somewhere that that was his first
that was his first role that actor wow
he killed it yeah he was great
he was good yeah i mean i felt like the
cost was largely pretty good like i i
did sometimes find it distracting that
um again protagonists unfortunately
don't know any of the characters names
and i feel like that kind of leads into
my point a little bit naru that's it i
think so does a lot of eye stuff she
does a lot of
just all the time like a lot of
just at everything a little a little bit
too intensely for me just a lot of eye
stuff going on
um but i also thought that she was great
the dog was very good
uh dog's name is sorry so yeah i don't
know i just it just was something that i
was surprised people loved it so much
because i couldn't see any emotional
connection or any way to even make an
emotional connection to this movie which
is something that i would think is
important for a survival or for
storytelling um am i wrong there mike
did you did you feel emotionally
connected to naruto well you're you're
you're expressing an opinion on the
internet about a movie so obviously
you're going to be wrong like well i'm
only asking for your opinion everyone
else i didn't ask i didn't ask
do not comment on this video unless i
got a piece of law about predatory i
don't think you're wrong i think
i think i
i think i enjoyed it just in a different
way than you i don't think i think you i
think i don't think you're wrong in
anything you're saying there i think for
me the pleasure of it um
is in the kind of
and this might just be unfortunately me
being a writer about it just enjoying
the procedure of the the setups and
payoffs and the way in which that kind
of that structure
just also as well there's just a delight
in that kind of i really i've always
been a fan of anything which shows a uh
someone who's good at something doing it
well so like um
uh like bear call saul every other
episode has like a procedure so someone
just like doing a plan and
working out um or like a heist movie or
like those kind of things like i enjoy i
love watching the predator because he's
so good at murder
exactly like this guy
he's well he gets it he knows what he's
doing
he's he's a pro he keeps getting his
helmet off which seems like a mistake
yeah yeah absolutely
um but no i think i think so i enjoyed i
enjoyed
um i enjoyed watching a nuts and bolts
80s action i enjoyed the same thing
definitely enjoyed the same thing and
that is why i liked it um
maybe maybe that
that maybe i'm not alone and just people
liked that more than me like i did enjoy
that um for sure
i just like i said i felt like i didn't
have any connection with the characters
the french being so comically evil
i was like okay
okay they're like like mustache twirling
evil it's like all right
except for the one guy um
and then there were like a few like
writing things that i was like weird
choice like uh when they're hunting the
eagle i believe it was at the start
they're just talking about hunting this
eagle and then she goes
by the way i saw this like invisible
thing that murdered something he was
like how does that come up and not his
priority this conversation yeah there
are a few things like that that i was
like
what yeah which
maybe i could just
i think i just got i just think i got
swept up
massively in the fun i think
i think watching it as well as like
entry five in a franchise like
definitely
going oh that's the predator that is oh
that's the predator he's gonna do the
thing the cat the guy just said if it
bleeds we can kill it yes yes
i think i think i was just in that mode
which is fair um yeah they're not
critical it is fun yeah i don't know i
just i think that maybe that's one of
those things where i was expecting it to
be
more than a predator movie based on the
hype i was seeing on social media where
like it is a predator movie it is a good
predator movie it was a fun ride i
enjoyed watching it i think that i maybe
expected it to be
yeah more emotional i think is what i
expected i expected it to like make me
feel something and i was like i feel
predator i feel predator he there i feel
it he's doing it
she's she's covered in mud but that's
not how she solves it this time like
that's really cool i i think i did enjoy
that stuff yeah i think a part of that
as well maybe i'm wrong but i think
maybe the thing that
i think the the the lack of complexity
which is part of what you're describing
not the whole thing but the lack of
complexity
may as well be part of it just in the
sense that like
if you're an action movie fan
if you look at what action movies have
been kind of cult favorite so john wicks
look another good example like recently
it feels like
the things that stand out now are the
action movies that just do the
just do it well just basically you
execute exceptionally well and like a
simple idea rather than going
for like depth or detail it feels like
but you know prevailing successful
action movies do that john wick
basically does a save the cat
of making you care about him deeply
because his [ __ ] dog dies
yeah the second that dog dies everyone
in the audience yeah you're it you care
about him yeah he's he you you want him
to succeed like that's it that like i
said it's basically a device so like how
do we get these guys to to care about if
you're working on a video game
adaptation you have to explain to
executives in hollywood that you can't
have a dog die in a video game
because
that was the whole thing yeah i remember
that conversation didn't i tell you what
i thought no go ahead sorry
no it's cool no school karen i was gonna
say what i thought john wick was before
i saw it
no i had i had this
i had only heard pieces of what john
wick was
and so i had it in my head that it was a
body cop drama
a guy and his dog go and like
find
criminals
i'd watch someone say
basically yeah like i knew there was a
lot of addiction
but i i really thought the dog was there
with him because the dog gets mentioned
so much that i was like this sounds
great i love the sound of this and then
and then that dog that dog really died
they could have done that with um with
sorry but i actually feel like this did
kind of
subvert a bunch of
how did you feel about the kind of the
kind of the
overcoming sexism aspect of what it felt
to me like they did stay on the line of
it not feeling like overwhelmed it felt
more like someone trying to prove
themselves rather than explicitly like
uh you know girl versus the world story
which i know i've saw people on the
internet kind of complaining about like
it feels like it could have been it's
there but it doesn't kind of push too
far with that yeah i could have really
disliked that i think if that's what it
were about um especially in this context
um i think that i would have been like
okay dude who wrote this script shut up
yeah um
but i didn't feel that way at all
because
what and i mean it definitely is a movie
that like presents sexism though it is i
guess
in her case
again she's she is kind of bad at the
start she does fail repeatedly she just
thinks differently she's just smart but
she doesn't realize that and i think her
failure being in
the fact that she
is uh wanting to
wanting to prove to the men that she can
do it just to prove it to them not
because she's good at it or enjoys it i
think is actually a lesson like that i
haven't seen presented in that context
if it's about sexism before there is
like for sure
i don't know i would have learned that
maybe like when i was 20 or so it still
took a long time really for somebody who
was always around more boys by virtue of
playing video games um
that
it you never you never will feel
fulfilled if you're doing things to
prove it to
people so um i saw this thing from
taylor swift recently who i like i don't
not like particularly a fan of like
indifferent and she said something along
the lines of i've decided to spend less
time
doing things that they think i can't do
and more time doing whatever the [ __ ] i
want
and that is for sure a lesson that i
feel like a lot of women
probably in competitive spaces have to
learn in their 20s
is stop doing things that men tell you
you can't do just so that you can be
like i can [ __ ] do that and just do
what you want to do
um and i think that it touched on that
in a in a a way that i've not seen
before so
yeah it
it was almost a little confusing because
um
the idea that she couldn't do stuff and
she was
not able to do the stuff the men do but
then being the reason she succeeded is
like it's a kind of conflicting
message
uh but i i think i just appreciated that
it wasn't trophy
i think that you know i did as well and
it didn't mean but i i think there's
another read and i think you could argue
that the fact that i've not seen this
read very much maybe
maybe implies it you know it wasn't
successful in convenience i think
there's also the read that the story
it's a story of a character who
is amazing
at
like observing tracking the kind of
non-combative elements but but not very
good at the combat stuff who slowly
realizes
that the combative element is not the
thing like she's actually consistent she
doesn't get better at fighting she gets
better at realizing that not like her
own skills
the ones she's already got at the start
of the movie like it's not actually a
power-up movie it's a
it's a it's a it's a uh uh better
utilization of existing skills movie
that's i don't know if i need to watch
it again to make sure that that's true
but that was definitely something i
stepped away with like it's all
it is that that character who's striving
to be like you know the warriors around
her and realizes that actually she's
they all failed because
you have to pray to be predator um which
yeah i i definitely liked it like it it
was a
more than anything like you know i
probably would also need to watch it
again and think about it a little bit
better
but my prevailing takeaway from the
sexism
theme that's loosely there is that i i
appreciated it doing something different
um it wasn't
i think i would have been annoyed if
she'd just like beaten the lion or the
tiger or whatever it was yeah if it was
like just like girl power kind of like
very shallow take on that that would
have been there was more of the like
yeah there was more of the threat of
believe in yourself
i recognize the skills that you have um
might benefit you in this situation like
your skills are not useless in in this
situation um which i i found to be way
way way more interesting so but i was
surprised they even touched on that in
general and then they sell the sequel
nicely yeah um
supposedly the gun breaks some kind of
law
no it's it plugs into law pistol is the
next time you see it
is with the predator which means that
it killed her
or she gave it to somebody at some point
who was killed for it
yeah it's it's going to be it's going to
be
that's that's the prop that's going to
be thrown around in the second movie and
eventually end up in the president's
hands presumably that's it it's left
there that's i think that's the
indication that the post-credits scene
shows like the
the uh that was a post-credits scene
well there's a credit so in the credits
they've got the they show the like the
cartoon not cutting sorry it's they're
like they're i don't know
beautiful
indigenous art of anyway i'm definitely
saying the wrong thing here um but they
show they show like the story of the
movie but then they carry on past that
point did you notice that so you see so
you see other ships arriving
oh
well i assumed that there was more than
one credit anyway because
that seems very inefficient for the
ships that size to just contain one guy
surely well you can fit more than one
guy on that ship
come on
well you yeah but but maybe it's but if
it's like a right of passage or
something maybe that's they have to go
by themselves maybe i also people assume
that the predators that they built the
ships they're on which is something i've
always wondered like if that's part of
the like because we know they're
scavengers so i've seen people say like
well how come he's not got cool
technology if he can fly a spaceship you
know blah blah it's like well you're
assuming that's his spaceship and that
that wasn't the last planet you know
it's true that they completely destroyed
i'm probably wrong there's probably a
book that explains why they have nice
spaceships i'm probably talking about my
ass but sometimes it's nice to theorize
without looking things up okay this is
how we used to be honest
i think i think that's something that is
true of like the predator is that
there's never been a lot on screen like
that's kind of i think one of the
reasons it's endured and people actually
still care is i think it's not got
whereas you know the xenomorph like the
alien stuff there's a lot more lore on
screen there's a lot more rules that can
be broken and people can get annoyed by
changes too whereas i think one of the
things with the predator is it's very
simple because it was a character
written for a
slasher movie like it wasn't it wasn't
thought such a good way of looking at it
it makes me appreciate predator i i
really like that the idea that he's just
a non-human slasher villain because he
is he just the the deaths are bloody and
gory and those soldiers
that's why you've got all the stuff that
establishes in the first half hour of
the original prayers like how badass
these guys are
so that when you see them get picked off
it's like immediately there's the
transference of badassery to the
predator that you're like wow if this
thing can kill these guys then wow yeah
i feel like this movie is the best girl
it's the tricks
which i'm sure he's thrilled about
well in this context you would be but
yeah i feel like this is the again i've
not seen
predators uh pretty sure but i think
this is the best movie since the first
movie because of the point you said
earlier which is that it actually
understands the theme um and it's it is
kind of the only interesting way to
tackle
a villain like that who is that
aggressive is to
make sure that you're not fighting fire
with fire because it's like the superman
problem
there's just no way it would work it's
not like predator is dumb but um i mean
they establish early on that
you know thinking that the apex predator
might be a snake is not the most
intelligent thing though i guess that
could just be that those snake tried to
attack
him he depends it depends for all we
know that's that's the norm on planets
the snake is usually that's true the
apex that's true that's interesting
predator fought superman at some point i
know predators fought batman i think and
i know superman's four aliens i'm pretty
sure there's a superman i wouldn't be
surprised
superman wonder who won
yeah yes
yeah there you go i look it up as well
oh my god the characters superman oh
yeah we knew that background predator
plot
a star labs expedition uncovers an
ancient dir an ancient derelict
spacecraft in the generals of central
america superman investigates the ship
and is inflicted by an alien virus
causing his powers to fluctuate wildly
okay
that's how they take care of superman so
oh but he also got a virus all right you
got de-power you've got yeah wow that
image of the image of him punching
predators off of cliffs
uh the group is captured by a band of
mercenaries working for a clandestine
scientist he plans to use the only
technology to facilitate selective
global genocide based on genetic
sequencing
but he didn't count on one thing the
meanest alien hunter in the galaxy
the predator senses superman is a worthy
opponent and begins stalking him while
concurrently seeking to reclaim the
stolen technology appropriated by the
scientist it's a race against time for
superman to save countless millions of
lives
don't know who won
the number of like pieces of pop culture
that are clearly like two ip executives
getting drunk in a pub and doing a deal
like it's 100 percent that it's like
this is i'd love to know like the
business case behind that of like fox
and dc doing a deal basically oh true
stuff yeah and i mean that was the thing
that i kept thinking with this movie is
i wonder how it was pitched
because it was for sure cheap to make
mm-hmm
it's beautiful it's a like i would love
to know where they perfect kovid movie
as well because everyone's outside and
far apart right it's usually just one
person they're very isolated yeah all
outdoors um but it's beautiful scenery
like beautiful just outdoor environments
nature wilderness um that's so cheap
like
i i wonder if it was scripted that way
and then sold because or or even
potentially wasn't a predator movie and
then sold that way um because
he did
he's um
dan trachtenberg is it tr trachtenberg
try he just literally tweeted about it
yeah so screenplay is by patrick azon
but he's he's worried about the high
concept so like his cloverfield
um his cloverfield he did the second
cloverfield movie with um 10 cloverfield
lane that's right i love that movie
yeah he he's a really good
story by me though he didn't write the
screenplay so i think he pitched i think
he's the one who walked in with like the
pitch of like native americans versus
predator i think okay so his idea so it
started that way i think that's right i
think he he talked about he tweeted
about that years ago i might i wonder if
it was i can't even remember if it was a
tweet it might well have been a tweet
yeah he's great he's um he also he used
to do like um like portal fan films and
stuff he's a he's oh he's the portal guy
yeah he's the guy he's a dice you've
probably met him i was just looking at
his face and was like i reckon i've met
this guy i she was just thinking that
and i was like
okay
i think that i've met whoever this is
um okay yeah that's it so yeah i think
it's just it's a it's i think that's the
other thing is it's that 80s thing again
it's just it's a great high concept like
you you hear the premise and you're like
yeah i want to watch that that's a great
idea that's a fun movie
yeah i mean it's again it's just i could
i could see it being a screenplay that
was pitched
i'm you're probably right um hang on
my alexa was calling me
um
it's just to take a
big
hollywood
franchise and then go we can make it for
like five mil has to be one of the most
appealing things in the world because
i'm assuming the predator didn't do
great right
because that was also that was shane
black coming off of like
iron man and like kiss kiss bang bang
like
so they probably paid a lot i imagine
that was quite an expensive movie did
you get it i also have
some like weird autism themes
it it did didn't it the kids yeah i
haven't seen it
but
it's an interesting movie
in black but yeah there's definitely
that in there there's a few things well
something about the predator like
thinking autism is a superpower and
wanting to obtain it
which um this is in the movie yes yes
an interesting choice
it's a set of choices there's it's it's
i mean yeah it's it's it's
in general like it's just it's it's
weird in a few different ways um okay
let's go
box office the predator grows 51 million
in the united states and canada
it definitely cost more than that
production budget of 88 million
yeah
globally it was 160.
okay so so the general rule is double it
right for marketing so it made its money
back yeah but not by a lot i guess it
ranked the fourth highest grossing film
behind predators the original predator
and alien versus predator at the
domestic box office so it did okay
because alien versus predator did for i
remember did really well like
surprisingly well of its time like four
four for a movie that's as kind of
schlocky as that i remember it did quite
well it
grossed
38.2 million over its opening weekend
wow an average of 11 000 per theater
like back then as well like that was
what early 2000s or like 2004
yeah
so
97 million at the so okay the gross
worldwide was 177 million making it the
second highest grossing film in either
predator or alien franchises behind
prometheus
prometheus is number one of alien and
predator
403 million worldwide
oh my god prometheus do you remember
though had amazing marketing do you
remember how like much hype there was
around that film yes and i went and saw
it in cinemas
um and actually i think i enjoyed it a
little bit more than most other people
did um there were things about
prometheus i really liked have you seen
the do you see the second one uh
covenant no
i loved i genuinely would recommend it
if you if you even
somewhat enjoyed from atheists you'll
love covenant okay i definitely like to
release though that would like it's a
sequel that genuinely like makes you
like prometheus more i think after
you've watched that like it's that good
um so i know that um
the marketing for prometheus
there was like this speech
um let me look it up
there's something that went viral for
them
i remember the head being like
everywhere yeah
i think it was just also people were
very hyped to see ridley scott go back
to the they had a ted talk video a fake
ted talk oh like with guy guy pierce
during the whole yes the whole birth in
character is peter weyland about his
vision for the future set in 2023 the
ted 2023 video presents a futuristic
vision of a ted conference an annual
technology
event blah blah blah the segment was
conceived and designed by scott and
lindelof and directed by scott's son
luke production was made in
collaboration with and made available
through ted that's so cool
um yeah it was it was
peter weyland just talking about what he
wanted to do for the future i i remember
that like really blowing up but i also
i'm remembering correctly that
at first
they didn't super explicitly confirm
that prometheus was an alien movie
i don't remember i don't know actually
they probably they maybe they flirted
with it i remember i definitely went in
thinking it was an alien movie okay i
think that going on maybe it's that we
didn't know how much
there is at the very end yeah well
that's the yeah there's the the weird
kind of proto with the spiky head yeah
yeah and now i remember at the time
people being annoyed of like that's not
a proper alien um which is what alien
confident spoilers is obviously bridging
that gap you you [ __ ] you should if
especially if you liked um
uh what's his name the guy who plays
david um
british actor michael fassbender michael
if you're like if you like if you like
fast bender in he was really prometheus
imagine a movie
people like that you need to watch
covenant you know
like yeah you'll like it because it's
it's much more about it's much more him
basically and much less everything else
yeah um but yeah yeah the ted talk and
then during uh wondercon in 2012
attendees at the films panel were given
wayland corporation business cards
that's cute yeah it's a lot of really
cool stuff um the business cards had a
number on it and after calling the
number the caller was sent a text
message from whalen corporation that
linked them to a video that was
presented as an advertisement for the
david8 android
very very very cool um yeah i feel like
maybe people didn't like that movie so
much because they felt like it broke
against somebody
yeah yeah that was because i think
that's the beauty that's why that's one
of the many reasons i'm a ridley scott
fan is because really scott doesn't give
a [ __ ] about the law like that's not
what he cares about like the best i
remember like the car if anyone want if
anyone's interested in like ridley scott
as a filmmaker like the director's
commentary on like the blade runner is
so good because it's basically him just
going
like
obviously blade running held up as like
great artistic achievement of a movie
and he just goes through the entire
commentary like absolutely diffusing any
idea you have that it's like an
auteur-driven piece of like he's he
talks about like there's these these
like these columns and he's talking
about i don't know it's like what's it
it's like people people always like it's
british
he's great grumpy so he's like people
always ask me why you know this is uh
why it's so wet and what i'm symbolizing
with that
why is it so wet and i say to them
because it looks [ __ ] good i was
walking through la and they just like
cleaned it and i was like oh water
that's nice isn't it it's just like and
you listen to this thing are you like
like it's just it's lovely if you're
like especially like as a as a director
myself and you as a writer and creator
as well like to to have like something
that is so like mystically elevated and
that's what you're talking to kirk hope
is like the when you i did that
interview with grant who i've been
friends with for such a long time and i
was like you see that this uh you know
this golden eye pause my new music has
like gone viral on tick tock and he was
like funny how that happens it's like i
was like what you know how what was the
process and he was like just sort of hit
some buttons in a room until something
sounded right yeah the [ __ ] clever
people clever people solving problems on
a deadline that's all that yeah that's
just it's really it's really kind of
heartening when you get when you see
evidence of that as it's like it just
demystifies and it's and you know if
you're you know people watching this who
are like you know coming up like yeah
that that should be massively inspiring
because that's all any of us are doing
and and yes there's there's hype and
there's like you know elevation of like
you know the auteurs and stuff but
they're just people they're just clever
people solving problems
true i also think tim said this when i
spoke to him too which was comforting to
hear from him
um
games in a c industry definitely i
imagine a lot of entertainment's like
this but i can't speak to him just
everything is always on fire
everything's always on fire and it's
just a matter of like your fire getting
put out but then another department's on
fire
like the whole thing is just burning
down and you're just trying to put water
on it the whole time and that's the
whole process
it's like it's been that way at most
companies that i've worked for
uh even ign was like that in a bunch of
ways it was like well that's on fire
right now
at least i'm not on fire like something
is always burning uh and that's just
how it is if you think something went
smoothly no it didn't
literally that's why you never get like
game developers to like great game
developers to organize like an evening
out because game developers are problem
solvers and if you put them on anything
other than like fixing a game
like if you if you get five game
developers to try and organize a party
they're gonna have built a pub by the
end of the day if they're not like
it's just this kind of wild kind of
specific kind of brain that like the
real the real greats in our industry
have way where yeah they they're kind of
they they kind of would be useless in
any other context other than like fixing
the creation of worlds that's the thing
that they were born to do and they're
they're amazing it's not a you're not a
super transferable skill but you know
doing our best that's why we need pr
people and marketing people and that's
why we have layers of people who talk to
the audience for us yeah 100 we should
never do a podcast as long as never any
of us ever go out in public and talk to
the audience
definitely definitely don't do that um
so the only other thing that i wanted to
say about prey was i thought that the
language stuff was really cool
which version did you watch
i watched english
but they don't even subtitle
the french or the comanche i think they
maybe did once or twice um but very
rarely which i liked i found that really
immersive the choice to just be like
doesn't speak in a different way it
makes it very powerful when the one
french guy starts talking to her right
yeah and she understands like that that
feels suddenly yeah i mean presumably in
comanche
based on what he says yeah because he
goes your comment we're just hearing it
in english um which i yeah i thought was
really cool and also props to them for
sticking to hiring uh because you
couldn't have done it without it um a
cost full of native americans like if
they hadn't done that
that would be horrific but totally like
it i'm just so glad that it was made
that way um and that yeah i did really
enjoy uh the cast i thought they were
awesome
the whole thing felt i know obviously
i'm
ignorant brit but if there was an author
it felt authentic it felt like people
involved in the making the film knew the
culture they were talking about or from
the culture they were talking about and
it had that ring of authenticity to it
which i found like very like again i say
immersive like just felt
real in a way that you know obvious
obviously a lot of like you know cliche
ridden
yes uh stories about those communities
that were made by people who were not
from that community
don't have that vibe no um
i should look up
their name but uh one of the producers
on the film was uh comanche um let me
look up the name because yeah yeah it
has that feel it has that i think so too
yeah yeah
and again like with no knowledge of
whether i'm right or not there's just a
there's just certain stuff you see where
where it feels you can tell it's
cohesive yeah you can tell okay so you
can tell
filming a code in calgary alberto
beautiful apparently congrats to calgary
uh yeah well done calgary yeah
james myers a
few too many bursts a member of both the
comanche nation and the blackfeet nation
served as a producer on the film
describing filming nick calgary maya
said we were shooting on stoney nakota
land
uh
mid thunder is part of nakota even if i
am on my grandmother's side usually when
we start a production someone comes in
and does a cedar ceremony and blesses
everything but because we had so many
indigenous people and cast first nation
people too and since we were on true
plains land they sent out two pipe
carriers and two smudge people to have a
pipe ceremony the pipe ceremony was
conducted outside calgary by local
indigenous leaders attended by mid
thunder and her co-stars beavers and kip
as well as myers and tretchenberg and
others so
he was even on indigenous land
um
which is awesome and yeah i'd agree
based on my
[ __ ] all knowledge uh it it didn't come
across no part of it came across as as
pandering or
cheap um in either direction for it also
female leader for the native americans
yeah and it didn't feel like it was
it didn't it felt like a storm
sounds so [ __ ] patronizing but it it
it didn't feel like it was
mysticising or like magical it didn't
feel exoticizing at all it felt like a
story about people living in an era in
history it didn't feel like
oh you know again like historically like
you know when like
usually a white dude directs a movie
about about about indigenous peoples and
kind of mr mr mr sizes makes it
you know it exoticizes it and this
didn't have that and that felt
that it just felt very human as a result
yeah i agree they do just feel like
human characters they didn't feel like
shamans like that's definitely a thing
white
if 100 like and and and i guess yeah and
pulled away from those stereotypes yeah
just felt great oh i will say uh
oh go ahead
no no
a lot of the language was super modern
they definitely speak in a lot of like
like 2000s terms
like but so what's your view on that
that's here we go this is our tangent
that will take us into our three third
and fourth hour of the podcast
language
yeah so like what's your
what do you
because because there's definitely
there's different schools of thought on
this right in terms of like do you do
you make it that the present audience
because because
she's a teenager she's hanging out
predominantly with teenagers should she
not talk like a teenager to in terms of
how the audience would understand should
she should she talk in kind of uh a more
kind of
historical voice or kind of you know
star trek for example has this kind of
faux shakespearean dialect that everyone
talks which kind of elevates it star
wars is more
um you know posh brits versus
americana like like
where do you where do you sit is do you
think there's a right answer on that or
do you think it's very specific to the
project or i think
in this case
again the language was so modern it's
like i think there were even some idioms
that it's immersion breaking that you
remember that you're watching
an actor in a movie that was made in
2020 or whatever um but that's not to
say that i think that she should be
speaking shakespearean she should
definitely still be a teenager and and
still was a teenager which i appreciate
because that's the thing that i think
they can
do a lot with women in action movies is
make them too mature too fast
she still did dumb stuff and made dumb
mistakes have i turned to the camera
what was that video game trailer that
came out this week where it's like oh
yeah i'm fighting dragons what was that
yeah
yeah yeah
not that is what you're saying don't do
that
you would you wouldn't have an opinion
on uh on another aaa game so i apologize
no
that is objectively bad marketing in a
way that's like
clearly the marketing uh it's because
you have i don't think that's what the
game sounds like i'd put money on the
phone that's not the video i think the
marketing team wrote that and clearly
you're making your protagonists sell
people on the game without showing them
what's cool about the game because it's
just somebody saying things over
gameplay it's such a bad
trailer it's just bad um yeah i don't
like i don't think people buy for the
team that game looks sick like it looks
cool it's just i really feel like it was
a marketing team who was like just do
this but then like
you know if you had even said some of
that stuff that you said hey it has to
be interesting she's like talking to a
cuff
if you feel that way about it you have
to make us feel that way about it too
and you didn't like oh so don't make it
don't make your teenage female
protagonist sound like a 50 year old guy
showing off you can but you have to make
it cool like
they could have said all those lines of
dialogue but had
reason for us to buy into what the
coolness was as well and it would have
worked it's
oh i'll probably make a video talking
about that to be honest um because like
i
studied marketing as part of my degree
and it's like such a small part of it um
but i actually think it's been the most
useful part of my whole [ __ ] degree
the thing that i pull on the most yeah
because like even some of the creative
writing stuff that i use at work all the
time now
the team would have just told me to do
anyway like it's not like i came in with
knowledge that they didn't already have
like here's how to write a good
character sheet and a character tree
like that stuff is like the team would
have just been like here's the template
do the work like yeah i didn't need any
of that
to be able to do my current job whereas
the marketing stuff um yeah i get a very
small part of my degree i didn't study
marketing as a degree or anything but
like that trailer was like such an
obvious marketing disconnect of
um making somebody sell something with
their voice without actually reflecting
to anybody else why the thing is cool so
then you just think the person doing it
is crazy like
super interesting
sucks though because i still think that
game looks cool
well i think that's a point i'd not i in
the much discourse that happened i don't
think i saw anyone make that point and
you're absolutely right that it only
comes across as weird because you
haven't got the visual context if the
visuals were like amazing oh my god this
is shocking
the voiceover wouldn't sound as weird
and it's paused differently like if the
visuals and the music had been like a
punch after she says that thing because
even saying fighting freaking dragons is
like okay but there's a million games
where you fight freaking dragons you
being that is really small
about that they could totally have made
it work it's just i really feel like
marketing team was like let's make this
trailer and they just really [ __ ] it
up
no it's smart i genuinely not thought of
it from that angle it's not it's not an
overabundance of bad vo it's an under
abundance of good anything else
and i don't even think the scripting's
that bad cheesy yeah but i don't think
the writing is the problem you could
have made that writing work just fine if
you had made us believe
or agree with what she's saying but you
didn't you just made her say it so it's
just like
that's smart and using your protagonist
to sell the game through vo is
is shitty like that's a really bad idea
like you can use your protagonist to
sell your protagonist but using your
protagonist to give you a sales pitch on
the game just makes people dislike the
protagonist use someone else's trailer
we ever did we did um we did one for
volume people should look this up it's
[ __ ] terrible um the announcement we
did for volume because we didn't have
much gameplay at that point was we just
did like an audio clip of our
protagonist be basically doing the same
thing if i'm honest i'm like i'm kind of
cool this is great and it's like it's
the trailer that we got the little next
stuff in the audience you can't you
should i'll send it to you after we've
done this because it is hilariously like
like to be clear not throwing shade on
my actors who were excellent it was just
a very like you said just a very bad
choice from me it was like the
announcement it was the voice over
announcement trailer or something and
it's just it's the same thing of like we
didn't have we didn't have the goods to
back it up at that point and we
shouldn't have put that out but um you
live and learn marketing's hard
marketing's hard
100 you live and learn i don't even know
how prey was marketed i don't even see
any of it also how did we get here was
it
yeah no well i asked you about like um
dialects and and
young and i like that again she made
mistakes and she was stubborn and
bullheaded like all things that i was
when i was a teenager
um
but yeah it was the idioms i think that
probably bothered me more than anything
else yeah uh i get that did you see i
guess i think my favorite example of
this is um do you ever see enemy at the
gates
no
that might be a bit yeah that might be a
bit i'm just realizing i used i used
mash as an example to a team member
earlier
i i used it with a team member and they
had no idea what i was talking about
i've never i just i just i just turned
to dust in that moment somebody not
knowing what mash is is
upsetting i work with like people in
their early twenties they they didn't
they had no idea what's happening it's
not still a re-running on tv everywhere
across the entire planet at all in the
uk anymore yeah not in the uk
but anyway the um
no the enemy of the gates is it's about
um russian snipers going up against the
nazis at the end of the second world war
and the the gimmick they have is the
russians are british and the nazis are
american so you and it and they stick
they hold they stick to their guns on
that in terms of like accent work and
and it's
it's it takes you a second like at the
start of the movie to be like oh that's
odd but the second it works it just it
just works and it clicks and even though
like further you know or um uh hunt for
red october where you've got the the
language change the famous scene in red
100 october like those kind of things i
find fascinating and and what's
interesting an enemy at the gates which
you i think you might like it's it's
interesting is there you're brilliant on
the idiom so you've got british guys
talking you've got you know british
actors it's what it was like when a big
breakout rule roll for um rachel wise
and jude law back in the day um
and they're talking but they are talking
about like they're using russian idioms
but they're you know speaking cockney
accents it somehow works that that movie
clicks weirdly well very interesting
it it is it's a weird one to describe
because then you've got oh god what's
his name um the
black hat from westworld
bull fella
[ __ ] call me his name
uh i don't know what it is you know what
i'm talking about yeah i know i'm
talking about yeah he's he's the he's
the the nazi sniper
joseph
probably not i just don't know who this
is joseph
joseph finds fine fines that is gone
isn't it
no joseph joseph finds every like
everyone over 35 just turned to dust on
the call as you mispronounced joseph
finds his name because where is he he's
disappeared i don't think he was massive
he was a proper movie star like back not
long ago
and and you've never no i'm talking
about um he's in handmaid's tale at
american horror i don't think i even i
like i was like well i could buy that if
he were like way older that this could
be black hat guy
um no it's um what's his name in
westworld and the audience is let me
just look this up he's good this is like
an episode hey let me let me double
check that real quick ed harris is ed
harrison
is that is that who i'm thinking it is
ed harris yeah yeah that's who i'm
thinking of so yeah he's he's the anyway
this has been movie time with mike you
should watch that's a good movie all
right
bob hoskins plays the russian leader
oh i do know bob hoskins you've got
score one alana
familia
look at me go
um
all right we've managed to talk for at
almost an hour about one year we stayed
weirdly focused it's almost like there's
some other element on the show that
pulls us off topic i don't know what it
could be
i don't know who it is or what it is
that's really strange
who knows
um but yeah i think like in closing i i
overall really enjoyed it there were
some things i didn't love and i think
that i i got too excited based on the
internet
this is a good predator movie it's an
okay movie it's how i feel i think i
benefited from the second i it went up
because i'm a predator fan and kerry is
as well like we we watched it that night
we didn't read anything we saw it was 90
minutes or whatever it was like an hour
and 40 minutes i was like yes nice
little quick action movie and it paced
really well great pace it's paced
amazingly yeah it tells a small story
quite quickly which works yeah but
anyway yeah i think i think it sounds
like the inverse of the conversation we
had about everything everywhere all at
once yeah it sounds like it's the same
thing it's not like i think it's bad i
just
expected it to be
something else genre defining almost
from the i was expect and this is on me
you shouldn't go into things with
expectations i think i was expecting
genre breaking i was expecting it to
push past predator and have some
profound thing inside of a predator film
but that's totally fine you should watch
predators
okay okay it might be the one you want
that might really well yeah
well it's it's it doesn't push past like
it's still this but it it it has a um i
don't know why it's trying to do a lot
it's trying to do a lot i i might be
remembering it wrong i remember really
liking i'm definitely going to go and
watch it straight after this recording
just to make sure i really don't like
the marketing like the trailer is sorry
that the
poster is not
it's not healing there is every chance
predators absolutely sucks and i'm
remembering it wrong i remember it being
entertainingly different at least
um i might be wrong i'm trying to see
what the recognition was critical
response
it's pretty bad mike it's pretty bad
i'm wrong 65 of 200 that doesn't mean
you're wrong
no it does it doesn't matter that's a
number no it's a number alone there are
a lot of numbers of facts
of facts
there you go not how it works just means
you feel differently audiences polled
gave the film an average grade of a c
plus on an a plus to f scale
um
some of the combinations
watching this movie i'm watching this
movie tonight i need to find out if i'm
right or the internet is
or rotten tomatoes is uh well let me
know what you think next week
thank you for watching everybody we
should be back that's a cliffhanger
hopefully
um
hopefully we should have the austin and
troy back you know just being busy it is
what it is busy yeah
we'll see you next week
[Music]
[Music]
you